>> Dagen: A DEMOCRAT SAYS
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS LYING ABOUT
THE BORDER CRISIS.
CONGRESSMEN ACCUSING THE
WHITE HOUSE OF SHARING
MISLEADING PHOTOS OF A CLEARED
OUT MY CURRENT FACILITY IN
TEXAS.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO EXPOSED
THE SAME JAM-PACKED PLACE THAT
BIDEN WOULDN'T LET THE MEDIA C.
MIGRANTS ARE SIMPLY BEING MOVED
TO DIFFERENT LOCATION.
THEY ARE MOVING FROM ONE TENT TO
THE OTHER TENT AND SAYING THEY
ARE NOT IN THE BORDER CONTROL
FACILITY BUT THEY ARE NEXT-DOOR
IN HHS.
THE NEWS HAS TEXAS OFFICIALS
FUMING.
SPEAK OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS CONCEALING ALL
INFORMATION FROM THE BORDER.
I WALKED INTO ONE ROOM AND IT
WAS EMPTY BUT THE NEXT ROOM HAD
1,200 KIDS IN IT.
YOU TAKE A PHOTO OF AN EMPTY
ROOM AND SAY NO ONE IS HERE OR
YOU TAKE THE PHOTO WHAT IS
REALLY HAPPENING.
>> LAST WEEK, THE FIRST TO
REPORT THIS, SHE DID A FLYOVER
WITH GOVERNOR ABBOTT OF TEXAS
AND SHOWS THE EXPANDED FACILITY
WITH ALL THESE NEW TENTS WITH
THE CHILDREN HAD BEEN MOVED.
>> Jesse: I TOLD MY TWINS TO
CLEAN THEIR ROOM THE OTHER
WEEKEND AND I SAID ARE YOU
FINISHED AND THEY SAID YEAH,
DAD, COME IN.
I WALKED INTO THE ROOM AND IT
LOOKS CLEAN AND THEN I LOOKED IN
THE CLOSET AND THEY HAD STUFFED
ALL THEIR DIRTY CLOTHES AND TOYS
INTO THE CLOSET.
THAT IS JOE BIDEN.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP
SAID FAKE NEWS MEDIA, TAKE A
LOOK, NO KIDS COME IN, RIGHT?
THEN HE STUFFED 1,000 MINERS
INTO A ROOM?
THIS IS CRAZY.
JOE BIDEN IS LITERALLY HELPING
THE CARTELS AND THEN PICKS A
DANDELION FOR JILL AND SAYS OH,
MY GOSH, WHAT A ROMANTIC.
REMEMBER THREE YEARS AGO,
EVERYONE TALKED ABOUT THE FLORES
SETTLEMENT.
U.S. LAW PROHIBITS THE
GOVERNMENT FROM HOLDING MINORS
FOR LONGER THAN 72 HOURS.
IF DONALD TRUMP HELD THE CHILD
PASSED 72 HOURS, THE MEDIA
CALLED HIM A NAZI.
JOE BIDEN HAS HELD THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN FOR OVER A MONTH AND
NOBODY SAYS A THING.
IS ANYONE PAYING ATTENTION HERE?
HE HAS TURNED THE BORDER PATROL
INTO A BUNCH OF BABYSITTERS AND
WHILE THEY ARE BABYSITTING
MINORS THE CARTEL ARE STRUGGLING
ADULTS AND MINORS OVER THE
BORDER.
JUST CONTINUE TO REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY.
HAVE EVERYONE WAIT TO GET
INVOLVED, THAT IS WHAT TRUMP DID
BUT HE'S TOO ASHAMED TO GO BACK
TO HIS TRUMP POLICY BECAUSE HE
IS AFRAID OF HIS BASE AND WANTS
TO SAVE FACE.
>> Dagen: IT DOES SMACK OF
NOTHING TO SEE HERE DESPITE THAT
A RECORD NUMBER MIGRANT CHILDREN
ARE IN CUSTODY.
LET'S SEE HOW THOSE CHILDREN ARE
BEING CARED FOR IN THE HHS
FACILITIES.
>> Juan: IF THEY ARE PLAYING
SHELL GAMES, HOLD POLITICIANS
ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT IS NOT GOOD POLITICS INTO
DOES NOT GOOD TREATMENT.
WE WANT TO TREAT THESE CHILDREN
IN KEEPING WITH AMERICAN VALUES
AND SORT OF, HUMANELY.
I WILL SAY I WAS READING IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" THIS
MORNING, IT SAID THAT CONDITIONS
ARE IMPROVING.
THERE IS A SHARP DECLINE OF
CHILDREN AND BORDER PATROL
CUSTODY AND WE ARE SEEING
CHILDREN MORE QUICKLY PROCESSED
OUT OF EVEN THE HHS FACILITIES
AND INTO THE RESPONSE OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE WILLING TO TAKE THEM IN
AND DEAL WITH THEM UNTIL THEY
CAN BE REVIEWED.
NO, IT'S NOT, JESSE, IT IS
SPEEDING UP SO THOSE CHILDREN
ARE NOT HELD IN ANY GOVERNMENT
FACILITY.
WE HAVE EVEN SEEN SOME REUNIONS
OF CHILDREN WHO WERE SEPARATED
FROM PARENTS DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
VERY FEW BUT TO ME IT IS A
DIFFICULT SITUATION.
I WILL EVEN SAY, YOU GUYS LIKE
TO USE THE WORD CRISIS, CRISIS
SITUATION AND WE ARE SEEING
STEADY IMPROVEMENT.
I AM STILL VERY FRUSTRATED.
EVERYONE CAN POINT FINGERS BUT
WHERE IS CONGRESS, WHERE IS
MARCO RUBIO, LINDSEY GRAHAM?
THEY WROTE AN IMMIGRATION BILL
IN 2013 AND NOW THEY WON'T EVEN
TALK ABOUT IT.
IT IS THAT POLITICALLY
UNMARKETABLE.
>> Dagen: IMMIGRATION REFORM
IS NOT GOING ANYWHERE WHEN YOU
HAVE THIS MANY CHILDREN IN
MIGRANT FACILITIES THEY CAN'T
EVEN SEE IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
ARTICLE SAID THE HHS DID NOT
RESPOND TO DETAILED QUESTIONS
ABOUT DETAILS INSIDE THE
EMERGENCY FACILITIES AND THERE
WAS SUCH INSUFFICIENT STAFF THAT
CHILDREN COULDN'T EVEN BE TAKEN
TO THE BATHROOM AND THEY WERE
FORCED TO RELIEVE THEMSELVES IN
WATER BOTTLES.
>> Dana: THAT IS TRAGIC AND A
COUPLE THINGS, LEGISLATION WON'T
GO ANYWHERE UNTIL THERE IS
BORDER SECURITY AND THAT IS JUST
THE WAY IT IS.
IT WOULD BE DIFFERENT IF
TED CRUZ HAD RELEASED THIS
PICTURE AND SAID LOOK AT THIS,
IT'S A TERRIBLE THING.
BUT IT WAS HENRY CUELLAR TRYING
TO RAISE THE ALARM, DEMOCRAT IN
TEXAS.
BUT PEOPLE THINK A LOT ABOUT
KYRSTEN SINEMA IN ARIZONA,
LITTLE BIT MORE WELL-KNOWN, AND
MARK KELLY, FRESHMAN SENATOR IN
ARIZONA, VERY TOUGH RACE COMING
UP, IN 2022, THE NATIONAL
REPUBLICAN SENATORIAL COMMUNITY
HAVE ALREADY ZEROED IN ON HIM
BUT WHAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY?
BOTH KYRSTEN SINEMA AND MARK
KELLY SAY WE NEED MORE FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THEY HAVE
TO DO MORE.
BORDER POLITICS ARE NECESSARILY
BREAKING ALONG POLITICAL LINES
BUT ALONG IDEOLOGICAL LINES.
IF I COULD JUST SAY, THOSE
STORIES THAT SOMEHOW THE
ADMINISTRATION, THEY DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF FINGERPRINTS ON IT BUT
THEY ARE ORGANIZING VIDEOS OF
FAMILIES BEING REUNITED AFTER
BEING SEPARATED IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BUT THERE IS VERY
LITTLE IN THESE STORIES THAT
SAY, DO THEY GET TO STAY?
AND WHAT ABOUT THE FAMILIES THAT
ARE BEING SEPARATED RIGHT NOW?
THEY KNOW CHILDREN WON'T BE SENT
BACK SO WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THEY'RE GIVING THEIR KIDS TO
COYOTES AND LETTING THEM DROP
THEM OVER THE BORDER.
IT IS JUST MORE AND MORE
COMPLICATED.
THE STORIES, I TIP MY HAT FROM A
P.R. STANDPOINT BUT IT JUST
REALLY, REALLY IS NOT THE FULL
STORY.
>> Greg: JUAN WAS CORRECT,
THIS IS A SHELL GAME AND IT IS
ACTUALLY REALLY CARTOONISH IN
ITS BRAZENNESS.
WHY DID THEY THINK THEY COULD
GET AWAY WITH IT?
LET'S MOVE ALL -- AND PULL ONE
OVER ON THE MEDIA.
IF THAT DEMOCRAT HADN'T PULLED
IT OUT, I WONDER IF ANYONE WOULD
HAVE KNOWN.
FURTHER OR LATER WE CAN MOVE IT
OUT BUT IT WAS EASILY ABSORBED
BY THE MEDIA, IT IS NOT JUST ON
THE BORDER.
SEEING THIS A LOT FROM CRIMINALS
AND MENTALLY ILL THAT HAVE BEEN
RELEASED DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
THEY END UP ON THE STREETS, THEY
END UP HURTING PEOPLE, WE HAVE
SEEN THIS A LOT, AND WHAT
HAPPENS?
SOME POOR LITTLE ASIAN LADY
WALKS UP THE STREET AND GETS HIT
BY A HAMMER OR GETS PUNCHED OR
SOMETHING, THEY THOUGHT THERE
WERE NO HOMELESS BUT THEY ARE
LIVING IN THESE HOTELS ALL OVER
NEW YORK CITY.
WE'VE GOT TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
>> Dagen: MY PROBLEM IS THEY
THINK THE A